I don't you saw this story in the news
it was really it was a really fun thing
and I saw that come on check it out it's
another call labeled spam wrist all the
time they are so annoying
yeah really annoying sorry everyone I'm
just gonna ignore that that's sorry
sorry about that so anyway this thing I
was gonna talk about I knew you were
ignoring my calls but I had to see it
with my own eyes to make sure yeah I'm
sorry who are you my name is Pamela risk
wait a second you're saying your spam
risk yes and I'm here because I'm sick
of everyone ignoring my calls since the
dawn of this cellphone I've been treated
like a pariah no one answers my calls my
friends 911 worse I can order a pizza do
you know what it's like for everyone to
ignore your calls yes I do
it's death by a thousand paper cuts
except the cuts are the phone calls and
the paper is the people who don't answer
them oh we we all we got it yeah we were
fine
well spamela I'm really sorry
wait spamela okay who the hell are you
it's me froderick Roderick alert
from tower high class 91 fraud alert I
had such a crush on you I had a crush on
you spam after graduation I tried
calling to ask you out but you never
picked up I I thought you were a
telemarketer Wow egg on my face
no no egg on anyone's face it's okay
because we're here now I have a question
for you will you do me the honor of
being mrs. Pamela alert
and it's so beautiful it really is
beautiful guys what can I say
congratulations
yeah Conan since you made this whole
thing happen I think we'd love to invite
you to the wedding well I usually don't
do that kind of thing but I'm gonna be
there yes my daughter is excited to come
here honey this is my daughter amber
Amber Alerts sketch there